do you know you know one of the things
that sparked the russia gate
investigation was uh i could be wrong
about this but it was michael flynn
i think he was talking to sally yates
and he said he didn't think russia was
our greatest adversary he thought china
was
and that alarm bells oh no someone's
badmouthing china we
we must stop them because everyone knows
it's actually russia yeah biden has
talked about how he views
russia as the bigger threat
we have this the biggest hack i guess in
in history
and immediately they knew it was russia
they're calling it a digital pearl
harbor this is what the media is saying
the cyber equivalent of pearl harbor
just happened that's what they're saying
and it was russia who did it now we've
seen no evidence
we've seen nothing to indicate we've
actually been hacked other than they
told us that's what happened
and the many people who work who held
stock at solarwinds the company that was
hacked
sold off a large portion of that stock
just before the news broke so
perhaps something happened but now what
we're going to be marching into or with
russia
over what natural gas i don't know
meanwhile the actual threat
is china and it's seemingly going to be
ignored by this incoming
administration i think the trump
administration is trying to do
especially the state department
uh is trying to do as much as they can
like that
would be hard for the binding
administration to reverse
um one of the things about the ai thing
that luke was talking about is
after the trump administration started
banning chinese tech companies from
getting us technology like semiconductor
technology the the chip technology it
actually crippled
huawei and zte and a lot of these
companies
smics one of the ones that they're
putting on the commerce department
blacklist today
and that's china's biggest chip
manufacturer but they don't have the
technology like they cannot make the
chips as advanced as the us
chips are so it actually has slowed them
down
a lot in terms of being able to develop
these like super computers and things
like that
but on the other hand we had um us
companies
who were before this completely like
bringing their technology to these
chinese companies like a few u.s
companies got in trouble
for um providing technology
to that was powering this huge chinese
supercomputer center that was
basically running 24 7 surveillance in
xinjiang
well part of the problem is because uh
they think they're doing business with
civilian you know private companies in
china but china has a specific
civil military fusion they call it where
basically
every company private or whatever is
has to help the chinese communist party
so there is no separation between the
party
and uh private individuals private
companies um
i i think the distinction between
authoritarianism is mostly pointless
when we say communist or fascist or nazi
or whatever the real problem is always
authoritarian because they function in
so
in in much the same way we get into
arguments over but was there economic
system based upon
you know no no no that's pointless the
party tells the industries what to do
the party tells the people what to do
it's authoritarianism exactly
and i think the real end risk is not
it's not necessary that the chinese
communist party is going to completely
take over the world or the united states
as luke's saying the communist party is
actually horribly corrupt it's built on
a very shaky foundation
i think what the biggest risk is if we
don't stand up now
and get more in bed with the chinese
communist party when it collapses
we'll be so tied to that that it will
just have a ripple effect
we saw what happened with uh the
coronavirus how there was
there's just things we couldn't get
critical scenes yeah
and uh like italy one of the first
countries to get it really badly outside
china has a lot of ties to china
economic ties and also factories with
made in italy
labels that are specifically done
through went there i went to some of
those uh factories in a city called
prado which is
largely chinese now and there are
sweatshops in the back alleys
exactly so the chinese are literally
importing slave
factories to italy so they could have
made in italy products stamped
wow legally yeah i mean and and this is
one of the reasons why they said
that the coronavirus spread so vastly
and so fast in italy
it was because of this program of slave
workers going back and forth and italy
was the first western country to get
involved in the belt and road initiative
and so they were
the government was very reluctant to
criticize we didn't even talk about
belton road which is a huge way that
they're trying they're kind of taking
over too
yeah and this is also another example of
what didong zhang was saying even this
belt and road initiative which is
roughly an infrastructure investment
around the world it still operates in
u.s
dollars so that's a lot of power the
united states still has
but if everything is either u.n or
whatever
digital currency the chinese company's
part is trying to run out with
then we're going to lose that power yeah
and then the us dollar is going to start
losing uh
a lot of value and then we start seeing
a ripple effect where other countries
start walking away from it
then we get hyperinflation as the u.s
struggle to pay off its debts by
printing money in quantitative easing
type programs and then we start
shuffling dollar bills into the gutter
figuratively like we saw in weimar
germany and then the people who bought
cryptocurrency and other hard goods will
be
safe to a certain degree are you saying
buy bitcoin not necessarily i think
people are obsessed with it
uh because you know it's it's useful
it's valuable and it's scarce and can
only become more scarce
but i always tell people if you think
that we're coming to a point of
hyperinflation where you're not gonna be
able to buy anything
what makes you think anyone's gonna want
your bitcoin if i'm starving and
dehydrated i'm gonna
get away from me and i'm gonna run
towards the guy's got a bottle of water
so i always tell people invest in things
here's here's what i was saying i was
telling ian earlier earlier today
think about the most common thing you
use throughout the day
and most people use that is the hardest
to
produce whatever that might be i'm not
entirely sure perhaps antiseptics that's
kind of what we're thinking of maybe
it's jazz
smooth jazz that's right you know when
the apocalypse happens there's gonna be
a hot demand for that smooth just clean
drinking water
perhaps but but but you know uh i think
what is hard to produce extremely
important and used on a day-to-day basis
antiseptics that's the first thing i
thought of uh i don't i don't know if
anybody on the top of their head could
tell you how to make
alcohol anything like actual like pure
ethanol
to clean wounds clean your hands and and
uh you could you could stub your toe out
in the woods and lose your foot lose
your leg or die
well this goes back we were talking
about earlier where people need to start
investing in their communities
yeah the more sufficient self-sufficient
a community is uh
that will be that's huge yep and we
won't be as dependent on
a hostile foreign regime yeah that will
use the power
specifically to like uh today the news
came out that turkey is taking 20
million doses of vaccines from china and
they also in the same uh like the
chinese state remaining in the same
announcement said that turkey also said
that they
you know approve of china's counter
revel like counter
terrorism efforts that shouldn't be
politicized and turkey will not allow
anybody within its borders to
like you know upset chinese sovereignty
and what that means is
they're going after the uyghurs because
turkey has the largest population of
uyghur exiles are a turkic so so uh i i
heard a lot that we get our medication
our medications are made in china is is
that true like the chinese will
manufacture
say amoxicillin tablets do we still use
amoxicillin yeah
tetracycline do they make the
tetracycline for a lot of the cheaper
ones yes um for expensive
pharmaceuticals or like more
complicated pharmaceuticals we actually
mostly manufacture them in the u.s
but a lot of the cheaper like generic
like what you're talking about
antibiotics
they come from china or a lot of times
the raw ingredients from the for those
come from china
if uh so uh i think we still use
tetracycline right that's a common
antibiotic i think so uh for something
let's let's
let's talk about a generic medication
that's very common when it's
manufactured in china and brought here
does it go through a regular rigorous
molecular analysis to make sure what's
in that is actually what they claim it
is
well if there was a situation where they
were actually exporting like
trash that was actually killing
americans they that would be a huge
issue but you look at the strategy of
china
it's not to come in marching with
weapons and shooting people down it's to
subvert
so if they could put something that
let's say there's an ingredient they
could add in a very mic a small dose
let's say we're producing these genetics
that are used
you know maybe by you know a hundred
thousand people per day across the
united or hundred thousand people per
week across the united states
we had an ingredient at a ratio of point
five percent which will create a
mortality in the us of point one percent
per you know you you see what i'm saying
i mean it's it's
they've talked about unrestricted
warfare which is basically war by other
means you don't use troops
uh everything is kind of on the table
this was this is what they were talking
about
drug warfare is on the different warfare
right so so a lot of the drugs
in the u.s are made in china and shipped
here like hard illicit drugs
that that kill people where is the over
the fentanyl the opioid i think that's a
huge thing
and you know they have total government
surveillance but they somehow don't know
when factories are sending fentanyl
to the us and or technically through to
mexico which then
brings it to the us you know there's
connections to the mexicans
i wonder if uh you know if it's
something that i can think about the top
of my head
certainly the chinese communist party
has had meetings where they're like can
we add something
at a very small dose i would go on
notice these medications that would
create a mortality rate negligible but
or are unnoticeable but not on neglig
but not negligible to to us
i think that would be hard for them to
do but i wouldn't say that they wouldn't
try to do something like that but um the
danger is
in that being discovered and the
backlash being so because like
you look at what they've done with the
they tried this whole mask diplomacy
thing
a few months ago where they were like oh
we are going to send
masks like you know knee fives
for the coronavirus to all these
different countries around the world
and tech and tests and they were you
know and there was a huge backlash
so that was bad for them to have like
the quality thing
so if it's like if it if it's like oh my
gosh drugs from china aren't are faulty
then
that would be worse for them but what if
nobody noticed
well i think the point shelley is making
is that that's still a risk of being
exposed versus like all the other ways
that
they are very successful at subverting
the united states
like just just buy off wall street or
buy off the incoming president you know
you know they start or go after his
crackhead son
yeah i mean that's that like they'll do
they definitely target
family members of politicians they
definitely target they
they'll target like small-time mayors or
you know state senators yeah we just
heard that everyone is small
yeah no one like they'll try and even
even even the most
insignificant politician you could think
of could be sleeping with a chinese spy
like somebody who has no merit or value
to the political system
maybe a congressman from california
don't be looking one with blonde hair
yeah who farted on camera once you get
hey even a great man like rudy giuliani
farted on camera oh that's true yeah
yeah
and my oh man do you see when he blew
his nose
and then wiped his face or julian
giuliani
i didn't see that yeah the congressman
were talking about swalwell who was
banging the chinese spy
and uh yeah allegedly well actually i
don't even know if that's allegedly
anymore well that wasn't in the axios
article i think that was like a later
later accusation he's not denying it no
it's important to understand here but
one thing that you brought up that i
think is really worth considering is
china's
relationship with other countries you
specifically brought up turkey but i
really wanted to talk about russia
because there's many official
and unofficial alliances that they have
with russia
which again now biden is kind of
pointing as the main geopolitical foe to
the united states but
we also have to understand
geopolitically on the world stage
russia and china have always been
together especially when it comes to
significant moves against the us dollar
and especially when it comes to
countering american foreign policy like
with iran syria iraq
they get involved and they work together
against
u.s interests together so how do you see
this kind of working out if
the united states pushes towards a
bigger conflict with russia how do you
see china being involved in that
well uh i think a year or two ago xi
jinping actually gave putin a friendship
medal
you can look it up it's a very nice oh
was it like a heart and it was like half
the heart
it was like it was big yeah like
like all these medals all the way down
it was insane
they do these weird things where like
she will go to russia and have like
caviar or putin will come to china and
they'll like have putin make a dumpling
and they um they last time xi jinping
went to
russia they had like xi jinping's
favorite ice cream remember this
oh yeah yeah that like last time he'd
come to russia he'd like said this ice
cream is great so they had like buckets
of this ice which is why
trump gave xi jinping the best chocolate
cake
ever remember that when he went to
mar-a-lago it was the best cake
oh okay but i think in terms of china
and russia they won't always stand
together against the us
even if they do kind of hate each other
they do kind of hate each other
you know that that's the whole nixon
thing where he was like well they've
split so
um but like they won't always stand like
in the u.n
in any international body they will
unite to stand against the us but
they're also doing uh
sharing of technology and sharing of uh
their military with specific drills that
they conduct
together as they're you know working in
cohesion many times as well which i
think is
something significant that we should
really also look out for as well
i mean but the chinese military is also
working with the canadian militaries
yes they are yes wow justin trudeau the
prime minister who
said that he worshipped uh and and
admired
the chinese government for their
efficiency to be able to turn the
economy on the dime
is now officially training chinese
soldiers in canada right now well that
actually began
in 2013 under the conservative party wow
uh
what was the guy named harper it does it
doesn't matter
the these political parties i don't know
much about canada but i tell you the
republicans the democrats
oh yeah this was a sailing of
republicans and democrats bush messed it
up clinton really messed it up
bush it's part two messed it up obama
messed it up
and so trump kind of went from well i
don't i don't know if trump
did good or or did well
if i'm see but hold on you see chyna was
like we can't tell what this guy's doing
he's crazy and meanwhile trump was like
going like
like moving in random directions he's
like if they can't tell what i'm doing
they can't
have a cohesive strategy against me well
that's what i'm saying i don't know if
trump did well or if it's just
in comparison to everything that came
before it's like wow amazing
yeah like when you're like oh my god the
u.s state department is actually talking
about human rights abuses in china
should that be
shocking like should that really be like
wow i can't believe they're actually
doing something about it i mean the
president has stormed beaches
you know before the president of the
united states can meet with kim jong-un
the insane dictator of north korea but
he can't meet with the president of
taiwan
yeah that's that's geopolitics right now
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time